der kollege martin der kollegin martin
renner als 1 65 geburtstag gefeiert
ihr kollege dr hans mittelbarer seinen
siebzigsten geburtstag gefeiert
[Applaus]
genannten kolleginnen kollegen
gratuliere ich im namen des ganzen
hauses für die heutige 98 und die
morgige 99 sitzung konnte zwischen den
fraktionen im ältestenrat keine
tagesordnung vereinbart werden
die fraktion der afg hat dem vorschlag
der anderen fraktionen wie versprochen
ich habe daher den bundestag mit der von
den anderen fraktionen vorgeschlagenen
tagesordnung einberufen nach § 21 absatz
3 der geschäftsordnung ist für die
genehmigung der tagesordnung ein
beschluss erforderlich
es gibt des weiteren eine
interfraktionelle vereinbarung die
vorgeschlagene tagesordnung um die in
der die vorgeschlagene auch noch nicht
beschlossene tagesordnung um die unter
zusatzpunkte liste aufgeführten punkte
zu erweitern und der frist städten
beginn der beratungen soll soweit
erforderlich abgewichen werden
vor dem tagesordnungspunkt 7 soll eine
aktuelle stunde mit dem titel co2 steuer
und ihre auswirkungen auf die
energiepreise aufgesetzt und die bisher
an dieser stelle vorgesehen die aktuelle
studie mit dem titel nach dem globalen
report zur artenvielfalt politische
konsequenz aus den gefährlichen abends
sterben am freitag als letzter
tagesordnungspunkt aufgerufen werden
der tagesordnungspunkt 8 zoll abgesetzt
und stattdessen nach dem
tagesordnungspunkt 10 der antrag auf der
drucksache 99 68
mit dem titel privilegierte
partnerschaft statt vollmitgliedschaft
eu erweiterungspläne für den westbalkan
zu überdenken mit einer debatten zeit
von 38 minuten aufgesetzt werden
ebenso soll der tagesordnungspunkt 24
abgesetzt und an dessen stelle der
anlage auf der drucksache 90 1 60 mit
dem titel rückabwicklung von
finanzhilfen für griechenland wegen
nichterfüllung und nicht mehr acht und
der kritik kondition im umgang im umfang
von 60 minuten beraten werden
schließlich mache ich noch auf zwei
nachträgliche ausschuss überweisungen im
anhang zur zusatzpunkte liste aufmerksam
sie hat das wort zum geschäftsordnung
gewünscht bitte sehr
herr kollege baumann die fdp wünscht
eine geschäftsordnungsdebatte zur
tagesordnung nach § 29 wie würdest du
das machst du geschäfte wahrnehmen sie
und sprechen sprechen sprechen wird der
kollege stefan brandl hat dazu der
kollege brand da würde ich das wort so
geschätzt dann haben sie das wort zur
geschäftsordnung bitte sehr
die brauchen kalte nation brauchen wir
keine debatte durchlesen
wenn das wort zu den geschäftszahlen die
größte und wird das erteilt durch die
regel
herr kollege frühstück sagt wenn ich mit
dem wasser bekommen
ich hab noch nicht gefrühstückt die
steht noch kein wasser ich hätte gerne
ein schluck wasser bevor berliner
kollegen einen moment bitte danke schön
wenn sie noch einmal platz nehmen wir
werden dass das wasser hinstellen und
sagen okay dann kann's jetzt das wort
und bieten neben dieser meine damen und
herren ist es an mir den
geschäftsordnungsantrag der fraktion zu
begründen wahrscheinlich so fordert mit
der einer von ihnen ausgekungelt wird
und für alle erwidert ich tippe mal auch
den kollegen buschmann der das macht
meine damen und herren aus zwei gründen
lehnen wir die tagesordnung habt der
erste grund ist ein weiterer bruch mit
einer langen parlamentarischen tradition
in diesem hause das ist der erste der
größten oppositionsfraktion obliegt den
ersten tagesordnungspunkt am donnerstag
der ersten oppositions
tagesordnungspunkt am donnerstag zu
bestimmen
das war immer so es ist plötzlich nicht
mehr so plötzlich gibt es ein
rollierendes system zwischen dem die
nachdem die größte oppositionsfraktion
also die afg und dann eine weitere
meistens die fdp diesen
tagesordnungspunkt bestimmen können dass
die fdp eine art wurmfortsatz der
regierung ist wissen wir alle dass damit
aber dass dabei deshalb mit
parlamentarischen tradition gebrochen
wird ist eine schande für dieses
parlament bei damen und herren wenn ich
über par
bayerische traditionen rede erlaube ich
mir an ihre tricks zu erinnern im jahr
2017 uns den seit über 100 jahren fest
stehenden alterspräsidenten zu versagen
und sich da in die tradition eines
reichs innenministers und eines
reichstags präsidenten zu stellen
auch da haben sie mit traditionen
gebrochen mein hotel aber der gipfel der
ignoranz und der willkür des umgangs mit
uns ist das was sie hier
mit dem bundestagsvizepräsidenten
veranstalten wir haben heute beantragt
eine wahl aufzusetzen wir haben drei
kandidaten vorgeschlagen meine damen und
herren es wurde von ihm abgelehnt
überhaupt nur die wahl auf die
tagesordnung zu nehmen damit verstoßen
sie gegen verfassungsrecht sie verstoßen
gegen geschäftsordnungs recht und sie
verstoßen gegen einstimmige beschlüsse
dieses parlaments hat die 40 absatz 1
des grundgesetzes statuiert bundestags
präsidentin und
bundestagsvizepräsidenten sie haben also
verfassungsrang wenn sie etwa 82 der
geschäftsordnung hineinschauen da ist
statuiert und es ist nicht etwa eine
lose abrede zwischen irgendjemand in der
geschäftsordnung statuiert das leder
fraktion und mindestens ein
bundestagsvizepräsident zusteht und da
wir eine fraktion sind von der rechnung
steht uns das zu da können sie erzählen
was sie wollen
jetzt könnte man sogar die
geschäftsordnung die geschäftsordnung
interessiert uns nicht weiter wenn es um
die afg geht genauso handeln sie ja
heute und hier auch wieder
es gibt aber auch noch einen
bundestagsbeschluss dem wir gefasst
haben am 27.10 2017 bundestagsdrucksache
19 schrägstrich 3
die scheint bei ihnen allen in
vergessenheit geraten zu sein
einstimmig einstimmig hat dieser
deutschen bundestag bei zwei
enthaltungen einstimmig beschlossen dass
jeder fraktion ein
bundestagsvizepräsident zusteht da gibt
es keine auslegungsmöglichkeiten my name
und darauf bestehen wir und deshalb ist
eigentlich zwingend deshalb ist es
zwingend dass natürlich auch der
tagesordnungspunkt zur wahl eines
bundestagsvize präsidentin aufgesetzt
wird meine damen und herren es ist
geltendes verfassungsrecht gelten das
geschäft ordnungsrecht und § 2 absatz 2
satz schon für buschmann wird
wahrscheinlich darauf tippen sie sind
oder mit leicht wahrscheinlich darauf
eingehen sieht vor dass mehrere
kandidaten zur wahl gestellt werden
können das steht ausdrücklich da drin so
da steht nirgendwo dass diese kandidaten
nicht von einer fraktion stammen dürfen
und seien sie doch froh darüber
wir bieten ihnen ein weiteres wir
unterbreiten ihnen ein weiteres personal
tableau mit fähigen persönlichkeiten die
wir ihnen vorgeschlagen haben die türken
mit modularen renner sie haben die
auswahl sie haben die qual der wahl
lieber als fraktionen so sagen sie alle
stellt doch einen auf dann wählen wir in
guten und jetzt wird es ganz perfide
jetzt setzen sie den tagesordnungspunkt
nicht mehr auf die tagesordnung
es gibt bestrebungen der fdp zu sagen
wir zu wählen wir noch alle drei wochen
ja was ich das denn für eine demokratie
so was klingt überhaupt nicht entweder
am in anspruch drauf und der statuiert
in der geschäftsordnung und dem
einstimmigen beschluss 19 schrägstrich 3
oder wir haben ihn nicht dann sagen sie
doch ganz offen dass sie keinen wählen
wollen ändern sie die geschäftsordnung
geben sie den beschluss 19 3 auf und
ändern sie meint gegen das grundgesetz
das wäre dann gerade die nicht von ihnen
aber zu reichen und dass sie beschlüsse
beachten hören und das gegenteil hier zu
tun das geht nicht deshalb bitte ich sie
kehren sie auf den boden der
rechtsstaatlichkeit zurück notieren sie
sich weiter die arbeit des bundestages
durch geschäftsordnungstricks verhalten
sie sich einfach die demokraten sich
verhalten in einer funktionierenden
demokratie vielen dank
[Applaus]
doch vermeidung von unklarheiten möglich
gerne aus artikel 40 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes den satz 1 zitieren der
bundestag wählt seinen präsidenten
dessen stellvertreter und die
geschäftführer gibt sich eine
geschäftsordnung
das ist eine vorschrift des
grundgesetzes dass die mittel des
präsidiums des deutschen bundestages
gewählt werden
kleineres worten herr kollege dass ich
die pflicht des bundestags bei der noch
des grundgesetzlichen zu weisen
jede zahl das wort zur geschäfts sondern
der kollege buschmann herr präsident
meine lieben kolleginnen und kollegen
zwei dinge zeigt diese maßnahme erneut
keine andere fraktion dieses hauses
steht mit dem prinzip des rechtsstaats
und mit der achtung vor den
institutionen unserer verfassung so sehr
aufs kriegsfuß wie diese fraktion der
ard
und deshalb möchte ich diese
scharlatanerie hier auch mal ein ordnen
sie ist nämlich ausfluss einer ansage
die ihr fraktionsvorsitzender in der faz
in einem interview wörtliches zitat
gemacht hat es soll hier nämlich im
parlament krieg geführt werden und krieg
ist kein wettbewerb kein sportlicher
wettbewerb sondern zielt auf vernichtung
an und was sie vernichten wollen ist das
ansehen dieses parlament und dieses
hauses
und dieses denke ich mir auch nicht aus
sondern in der faz vom 04 04 2009 10 ist
zu lesen
die fa die fdp droht damit die arbeit
des bundestags systematisch zu behindern
und dann wörtliches zitat aus einem
internen papier
ich zitiere aus der faz die aus ihren
papieren zitiert in jeder sitzungswoche
finden dann zeitraubende walenstadt das
werde zitat das ansehen des bundestags
nachhaltig beschädigen und das vertrauen
in unsere demokratie erschüttern und
darauf legen sie es an schämen sie sich
und wie gehen sie vor um dieses ziel der
untergrabung des ansehens des
bundestages hier zu erreichen
sie machen taschenspielertricks und zwar
die geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages sieht vor dass wahlgänge im
zweifel zwar nur dann stattfinden wenn
sie vorher angekündigt mit drucksache
verteilt sind oder eine schutzfrist von
drei wochen gilt das ist ausfluss der
wehrhaften demokratie um sich gegen
verfassungsfeinde in diesem haus nämlich
zur wehr zu setzen und dass wir auf
diese regeln bestehen dass wenn wir auf
diese regeln bestehen wenn sie uns mit
ansage den krieg erklären
da dürfen sie sich nicht darüber
beklagen deutschland ist eine wehrhafte
demokratie gegen leute wie sie
und was sehen der sache vortragen
entbehrt jeder juristischen logik
deshalb ist es hier vermutlich ihrem
ersten pdf auch zu peinlich dass ihr
vorzutragen da muss ja brandner hier in
die bütt steigen
da muss er brandner in die bütt steigen
um uns zu erklären dass die wahl eines
vize-präsidenten die wahl eines
vize-präsidenten ein benennungsrecht
seiner fraktion werde ich darf sie
aufklären sie haben ein vorschlagsrecht
wählen tut der bundestag mit mehrheit
und daran werden sie nichts ändern
und der vorschlag von gleich drei
kandidaten aus einer fraktion für eine
position wo in allen benennungsrecht
zusteht ist nicht nur rechtlicher blöd
sind es ist an peinlichkeit nicht zu
überbieten jeder mensch mit gesundem
menschenverstand wahr ist dass wenn ich
ein vorschlagsrecht für eine position
habe dass sie nicht drei kandidaten
vorstellen kann und das ist ja das ist
ja ein fortsetzungsroman mit ansage wir
wissen ja worauf das hinausläuft
sie wollen dann nämlich am ende
behaupten wenn sie drei kandidaten
vorschlagen dann würde im dritten
wahlgang die relative mehrheit reichen
und wer dann mal gerade eben die stimmen
ihrer fraktion hat der ist es dann
sie wollen ein wahlrecht umwidmen in ein
einseitiges benennungsrecht das ist
undemokratisch das ist verfassungswidrig
und auch solche hütchenspieler tricks
werden wir nicht hereinfallen
deshalb meine damen und herren unser
parlament hat regeln
unser parlament kennt ordnung und diese
regeln und diese ordnung sind dazu da um
uns gegen obstruktion wie sie sie
vorhaben zu schützen wenn sie uns den
krieg erklären davor haben wir keine
angst denn unsere verfassung ist
wehrhaft gegen leute gegen sie
herzlichen dank
klein report meldungen zur
geschäftsordnung liegen mir nicht vor
wir kommen damit zur feststellung der
tagesordnung der heutigen 98 und der
morgige 99 sitzung mit den zuvor
genannten einvernehmlichen ergänzungen
wer stimmt für diese so ergänzte
tagesordnung
wer stimmt dagegen enthält sich da nicht
die tagesordnung gegenstimme der afg mit
den stimmen der übrigen fraktionen zur
beschlossen